oh yeah we're going yeah hey my favorite
thing about Canada ketchup flavored
potato chips [__] law
what's your favorite thing about Canada
what's up there yeah man I could hang in
Kelowna for years on the shrimp let's go
to Vancouver you can't really see how
one of those might [__] someone
this is Archer from Victoria BC I mean
let's look at the detail here man [__]
are you [__] kidding me aren't you
dude
look at that [__] I have a small wine I
know I know what is this see cuz this
was the hardest thing I couldn't figure
that out yeah that is the same tattoo
Angelina Jolie has a name older yeah
done by the same holy man in Thailand
and you want to know what it means what
does it means I wanted to bone Anjali in
a joke that's the much sweet
yeah I know do you what's going on see
what we will have him to us
how are you buddy I helped it out a
couple of chicks that they want to
whoa we're getting ready to drive to
Arizona the first for eating lunch and
it looks like there must be something
going on what's up dudes who do we got
here
oh yeah he's at regain again already
Donovan cool man
all right we're heading to Phoenix and
I'm sorry that I've been [__] so
swell on all the vlogs yeah yeah yeah
all right man
time for a skate break
you
Walter water I'm your father
what are you batting practice with the
Arizona Diamondbacks
but I couldn't turn time it's a batting
cage terminology take one for the team
yeah well maybe I guess I'm jump in here
yeah all right
I'm steve-o this is called taking one
for the team
oh yeah thank you so much [__] nice
to meet you yeah getting ready to go on
and I'm wearing a [__] pimp suit
if you're not already subscribed to this
channel what are you thinking
[__] subscribe and if you don't
already have an autographed steve-o book
and a steve-o t-shirt and a steve-o hat
well [__] get it and what else man
[__] is there some hot [__] coming at
you man ah it is on on on you know what
else it is is the age of the selfie yep